foreign
[Music]
to the visual edition of the backstage
podcast with all of the latest reviews
and interviews from the world of TV and
film and I'm joined by Sky's
entertainment reporter Claire Gregory
hello and coming all the way from New
York it's uh Stevie Wong TV and film
reviewer
and we are going to be speaking this
week to man of the hour Harrison Ford
who's been talking to us here at
Backstage and we're going to bring you
all of the latest uh from the world of
TV including this
dad told me you found something
on a train during the war
so gorgeous I know
next thing you know one Mania had
arrived we are at War
whatever it takes
you're going to get back
first up it's finally out in the UK the
fifth and apparently final installment
of Indiana Jones We've been waiting for
Harrison Ford to return to us in the
iconic role that we all grew up with as
uh with his hat in in full archaeologist
mode and Claire Gregory this week you
were lucky enough to talk to him no can
you imagine My Little Star Wars heart my
Star Wars fan heart beating so fast
because uh of course Han Solo is an
absolute Legend Harrison Ford is an
absolute Legend and he had a Jones is an
absolute Legend so it was a big week for
me uh going down to the red carpet to
have a chat with the stars of the fifth
and as you say possibly final no well
look we're here what the Stars had to
say to you in a little bit but first
should we check out what the film looks
like this is dial of Destiny Hitler made
mistakes and with this I will correct
them all you stole it then you stole it
and then I stole it it's called
capitalism
this way
[Applause]
seat belt there might be some tablets
you've taken your chances made your
mistakes
and now a final Triumph
so Claire I mean Harrison is a hard man
to talk to at the best of times well
he's not known for being completely like
chipper and happy all at all times is he
luckily that wasn't my experience he was
absolutely charming and wonderful and
and Brilliant
um and we we had a good chat and I what
I was kind of trying to get my head
around what it's like to play this
character you know kind of four decades
on from when he first played it you're
kind of ending his story and here's what
he had to say about that I mean it's 42
years we've been going on with this and
and
but the only the reason for that I think
is because these are family films and
they're passed on from generation to
generation of young uh people when their
parents feels it's the right time it's
quite incredible to think that he is 80
years old and doing all of that now
isn't it and of course we get to see him
young as well don't we Stevie because in
the film itself they've de-aged him for
part of the action
it's so weird to see like almost maybe
30 or 20 minutes of the film basically
it's him looking like a much younger
version uh and kind of the Harrison that
we kind of walked in on in the very
first Harris you know the Indiana Jones
and so to see that part uh and the
technology that's not quite right
yeah
isn't it it's young Harrison but it's
not really young Harrison the man is
still extremely agile and active and
stuff but to to see him go through this
uh it is fascinating is the film that
good I don't know what do you guys think
I mean should we even let's not spoil it
for people who have fun
will anyone care what we have to say you
just want to see the new Indiana Jones
which of course this one around is
featuring fleabags Phoebe Waller Bridge
who you also got to catch up with yeah
that's right so they they teamed him up
with her she plays his goddaughter and
uh you know helps out with all that
action as well
um and of course everyone is just
talking about it being Harrison Ford's
last time and she said it definitely you
know it definitely had an impact on
filming yeah it had a real gravitas um
the whole experience actually and even
when we were doing the this is a mad cat
fun stuff every now and again it would
hit us that this is you know the last
adventure he's going to go on and it's
um yeah it's very meaningful and I feel
like you know I think it's very obvious
how meaningful it is to Harrison and you
know we were all on that Journey with
him so it's a real privilege how about
just a very brief tease then of what we
thought what do we think I wild ride I
loved it Bonkers ending
[Laughter]
the last 10 minutes is very odd isn't it
it's a bit it's a bit even for Indy it's
a bit odd yeah it's a bit much Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny is out in
cinemas now literally should we move on
if you're a fan of 80s music this one is
for you Netflix is releasing its uh new
documentary all about the band Wham
hairspray at the ready come on put your
little tight shorts on this is one for
you
[Applause]
[Music]
let's introduce the band George I'm
Andrew
we had a number one album we had a
string of hip singles and we were
selling out arenas
so for those of you that were perhaps
too young to remember of course Wan were
made up of uh George Michael and Andrew
Ridgely and this is a delightful little
insight into how uh shorter time they
were together it's incredible isn't it
1982 to 1986 and this is a beautiful
kind of mixture of home videos and
interviews with the boys as well
basically telling their story and the
director behind this Chris Smith he's
known for huge documentary hits like he
did Tiger King and the fire Festival
dark and bad vegan so you will have
probably seen some of his stuff before
and you know how great he is with
archive and never before seen footage I
really enjoyed this Stevie did you enjoy
the Nostalgia trip
it it is a lockdown A Memory Lane that
you know I'm more than happy to say that
I was around when this happened and you
know I I it did throw me off that it was
only four years in the making though
because right uh growing up as a child I
thought this was much longer maybe time
much longer than your kid and uh but it
is it is so strange that they became
Global Superstars uh in such a short
period of time and it also proves the
fact that like George Michael's
songwriting skills his producing skills
was so uh Timeless I mean these songs if
you play them not they're still quite
popular if you you know any of those
radio stations the second you heard that
fear that first note you knew
immediately what the song is and you can
sing along to it and stuff and and uh I
it it also tells me that you know we
lost somebody like George too way too
soon and and uh what kind of magic you
would have still continued to do and
some brilliant anecdotes as well I love
the um did they know it's Christmas
versus last Christmas where George is
like I've come up with the best
Christmas song ever it's gonna be so
good and then out of nowhere Bob yelled
off emerges from the Shadows but we've
got to do a charity song and George is
quietly inside crying that this was
meant to be my year but no I'll come and
sing on your song lots of fun anyway wam
is out on Netflix on Wednesday the 5th
of July now shall we move on to
something a little bit more trashy now
if you're a fan of you know
succession
meat something a bit more kind of soapy
and footballers wives now this this is
the show for you it's riches it's out on
ITV it's about a group of siblings who
are fighting for control of their
fathers Empire take a look here's what
it's about no
everyone is trying to Scramble
for a piece of the black pound
our father is dead I don't care
that man abandoned us with nothing go to
London then see the woman who chose over
us
you think you're safe here if they want
my company
fight me for it so this is very
interesting particularly because one of
the writers of this show also did
inventing Anna so does that give us a
kind of idea of the sort of headspace
you're getting with this yeah so Abby AJ
she worked with Shonda Rhimes on
inventing Anna which was a Netflix show
um and uh she was also one of the
writers on how to get away with murder
so um these are kind of big shows and it
sort of maybe would later lead us to
think we know what to expect so to make
more prestigy kind of drama but this is
not it's this it reminded me of like the
Soaps of old I'm talking Dallas talking
Dynasty yeah I'm talking Women shouting
at each other across the boardroom table
you give me my husband's money back
possibly throwing things and uh yeah
snarling and and all this kind of thing
I grew up on on those Dynasty and
delicious I love a good cat fight I mean
unfortunately there was no pool for
these two women to like fight in
but but I mean there
and then wiggling and then just whole
thing is just they knew exactly what
show it was and so you know from the
very second onwards it's it's an
underdog going into this Rich kind of
family who don't want them and they have
to prove themselves and it is uh you
know it's it's the basis of any kind of
good soap opera you see it all in kdrama
these days and then I mean globally
that's a that's a plot line that
everybody can relate to and so uh riches
knew exactly what it was about and I
don't think the the comparison to
succession is fair well that's riches
which is available to watch now on uh
itv1 and that's it for this week if
you've enjoyed what you've listened to
don't forget that there is the longer
version of the actual backstage podcast
which is available to listen to complete
with Claire Gregory's uh longer
interview with the man of the hour
Harrison Ford just make sure you either
scan the QR code which is on the screens
now or look up your podcast however you
normally get them just search for
backstage thank you to Claire and thank
you as well and we'll see you again soon
bye